hi this is press Locker in this video
I'm going to teach you a math trick to
multiply two numbers that are between 11
and 19 in your head let's do an example
of 13 times 12 the trick I'm going to
show you involves three different steps
the first step is to take the entire
number 13 and add it to the digit 2 the
result is 15 and we're going to put a
zero after that number the second step
in the process is to take the digits 3 &
2 and multiply them together the result
is 6 the final step is to add our
intermediate results together and 150
plus 6 is 156 and that's our answer so
we'll do one more example to illustrate
the process will do 19 times 14 the
first step is to take the entire number
19 and add it to the digit 4 to give us
23 we put a 0 after the result the
second step is to take 9 times 4 which
is 36 and the final step is to add those
two intermediate results together to get
266 I hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math and game theory you can also check
me out and my blog mind your decisions
or on twitter at pressure Locker